LONG.
>> YEAH.
BIG TIME FOR OF THE
TABLE.
>> CONNOR McMICHAEL WILL REV IT
EXCELLENT SHOT TRYING TO GO
UPSTAIRS.
MISSESES A BACKHAND
STOP BY DAWS.
WHEN DO YOU START TOTOTHE POST.
>> THAT WAS BACKSTROM AT KUZY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOUYEARS
OF AGE.
VITEK, TALKED ABOUT HIS SUCCESS
AGAINST THE DEVILS.
HE'S HOPING TOWAS BORN IN IN HI
HAMILTON, A SLAP PASS THAT WAS
INTENDED FAN ODD MAN BREAK.
THATCEK
DROPPING IT OFF.
CARLSON ON THE INTERCEPT.
NOW, AN ODD MAN OR HOLDS, HOLDS
AND TO
THAT GOALIE.
NIKO DOD.
BEATENRE ON  THE
MOVE TO CENTER.
>> DOUGIE PLAYS IT.
INSIDE OF CAPITAL ONE ARENA.
WASHINGTON WILL PLAY HOST TO
DEVILS.
CHANCE PASS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THEY MOVED AROUND EVERYBODY
STRENGTH.
THIRD PERIOD GOAL FOR
McMICHAEL.
THAT WAS A BEAUTY.TO GETTING IT
OUT.
THE DANGER ZONE.
A LITTLE POKE THERE POST BACK-T
WINS AFTER THEIR TRIUMPH LAST
NIGHT OVERFOR THE DEVILS.
KUZNETSOV.
STROLLING THROUGH CENTER.
4-3 ABSENSE.
FOURTH OF VECHKIN.
ADD ANOTHER TOE IT IN TIGHT
STOP.
VANECEK FIRES.
>> THAT'S CALLED A QUICK REBIND
IN THE NEUTRALS.
AND IT'S THE SPEEDTHEY'RE WITHI
SHARP ANGLE SHOT WITHIN 63. NOW.
4-3. DAWES MAKES A BA GREAT